Game of Thrones Season 6 Episode 1 just came
out and some pretty crazy stuff happens so
let’s get into it.
We begin at the Wall with Jon dead in the
snow.
Davos and Ghost and some loyal Night’s Watchmen
are in conflict with Alliser Thorne, who seems
to be taking over the Watch after Jon’s
death.
Edd goes to get the wildlings – who probably
won’t be too happy when they hear what happened
to Jon.
Melisandre comes and says she foresaw Jon
fighting at Winterfell, and, well, so have
we – that’s probably him there in the
trailer.
There’s heaps of evidence in the books and
the show that Jon will be back – “he always
comes back”.
The only questions are how and when and in
what he’ll be like when he rises.
But in the meantime, conflict is brewing with
Watchmen and wildlings and Davos.
In Winterfell, Ramsay is also mourning his
dead in his own special way – “feed her
to the dogs”.
Ramsay’s dad Roose reminds him that Sansa
is the Bolton’s best hope of controlling
the north, and also that if Walda has a son,
that son would inherit Winterfell ahead of
the bastard Ramsay, so some people think that
Ramsay might end up killing Walda and Roose
this season.
Meanwhile, Theon and Sansa are hunted by Boltons,
Theon bravely risks his life to try to protect
her – which could hint at the beginning
of redemption for him – but the Boltons
close in, but Brienne and Pod appear to save
the day and carve up the Boltons.
Sansa finally accepts Brienne’s service
and protection, which is a beautiful moment
for Brienne, mirroring her pledges to Renly
and Catelyn.
Hopefully she’ll have better luck keeping
Sansa alive.
In King’s Landing, Cersei is still reeling
from her walk of shame, and she’s crushed
even further when she finds out her daughter
Myrcella is dead.
She talks about the prophecy of Maggy the
Frog, who said that Cersei’s kids would
die.
It’s interesting that the show hasn’t
mentioned the other part of Maggy’s prophecy,
that Cersei will be killed by her valonqar,
or little brother, which she thinks means
Tyrion, but some readers think means Jaime.
In any case Jaime says fuck prophecy, fuck
everyone else, we will take everything back,
which will put him at odds with the Faith.
Here we see the High Sparrow and Septa Unella
playing good cop bad cop with Margaery Tyrell,
who is still imprisoned along with her brother
Loras.
Cersei is not exactly the biggest fan of the
Tyrells, so it’ll be interesting to see
how much the Lannisters and Tyrells join forces
to face the Faith.
Down in Dorne, Ellaria and Tyene suddenly
kill Doran and Areo, and Obara and Nymeria
kill Trystane in King’s Landing, and this
is pretty crazy.
Cause the motivation of the Sand Snakes is
that they want to start a war against the
Lannisters because the Lannisters, or rather
the Mountain, killed their father Oberyn,
and earlier, their aunt Elia.
Doran tries to prevent war and that seems
to be why Ellaria kills him.
But isn’t it kinda crazy to kill Oberyn’s
family so you can avenge Oberyn?
Further, Ellaria and the Sand Snakes are all
bastards, with no rightful claim over Dorne
– will they even be able to take control?
Many book readers don’t like this change,
but maybe the show’s just cutting to the
chase, getting to the point, which is probably
that Dorne will war against the Lannisters,
and probably end up supporting the Targaryens
– Daenerys in the show, but maybe Aegon
in the books.
Also it’s cool to see Obara and Nymeria
in King’s Landing – might be they’ll
get in on the conflict, maybe they’ll kill
Tommen, as Nym threatens in the books.
It might also make sense for them to go after
Robert Strong, the reanimated Mountain, ‘cause
after all, he’s the guy who killed Oberyn
and Elia.
Varys and Tyrion rock some sweet capes, talk
about the rising political tension and the
threat of the Sons of the Harpy, and all this
doom and gloom looks to put Tyrion in a good
mood.
He’s really starting to shake off his earlier
depression, he’s getting back into the game,
so it’ll be great to watch what he and Varys
can accomplish together.
They pass a red priest preaching about Daenerys
being Azor Ahai, which is cool, and might
foreshadow the arrival of the priestess Kinvara
sometime later.
It’s interesting that the priest wears the
same hexagonal pattern we see on Melisandre
and Quaithe – maybe meaning this guy’s
from Asshai.
Finally we see Dany’s fleet burning in Slaver’s
Bay, and Tyrion’s all like, looks we won’t
be sailing to Westeros, but wouldn’t it
be convenient if we knew some friendly Vikings
who could bring Dany some ships…
Meanwhile, Jorah and Daario search for Dany
in the Dothraki Sea, they have a bit of banter
to stoke their rivalry, we see that Jorah’s
greyscale is getting pretty gnarly, and Dany’s
on the road to Vaes Dothrak, the Dothraki
city.
Dany suffers the whips and harassment of her
captors, and keeps her cards close to her
chest, only revealing that she can speak Dothraki
when she’s brought before Khal Moro.
For a moment things look like they might turn
around, but then Dany finds out she’s expected
to join the dosh khaleen, the “widows of
dead khals”, who live out their days in
Vaes Dothrak, which is probably not what Dany
had in mind.
But in the books, Quaithe tells Dany that
“To go forward [she] must go back”, so
this return to the Dothraki could be crucial
in Dany’s arc moving forward.
She won’t want to hang around the Dothraki
forever though, so wouldn’t it be convenient
if we knew a friendly dragon who could fly
in to spirit her away…
In Braavos, Arya is still blind, and is begging
on the streets.
You can briefly hear someone saying “after
what happened to that Kingsguard”, which
is a reference to Arya’s murder of Meryn
Trant last season, which is cool.
But anyway “the waif” turns up, and proceeds
to beat the absolute shit out of Arya, which
is meant to train her to use all her senses,
though in real life that kind of beating would
give you a fractured skull before Daredevil
vision, but regardless this suffering will
probably make Arya stronger.
Even so, there might come a day when Arya’s
had enough of the waif’s shit – so we
may soon see real conflict between the two.
One little thing in the books is that Arya
gets around being blind by warging into a
cat – entering into its consciousness and
seeing through its eyes, like Bran does with
Summer.
Hopefully they’ll include that in the show.
And then, back at the Wall, Melisandre reveals
her true form as a very very old woman, which…
actually makes a lot of sense.
It’s hinted in the show and the books that
Mel is older than she seems , that she’s
hiding her true appearance with a kind of
magic called a glamour.
The glamour seems to work using this ruby
at her neck, though she has been seen without
it before without looking old.
Maybe that’s a continuity error, maybe the
magic works some other way, but the real point
here is that Melisandre’s nakedness shows
where she’s at as a character right now.
Remember, when we first met her, she seemed
so powerful, so beautiful, so certain . But
all of her hopes and beliefs were founded
on Stannis Baratheon being Azor Ahai, the
chosen one of the Lord of Light, and now that
he’s dead, she’s lost everything.
Her nakedness is a moment of honesty and vulnerability
and humanity, from someone who’s now in
deep doubt over who she is and what she believes.
It’ll be amazing to see how she comes out
of this, and what it might mean for Jon Snow.
So that is Episode 1 of Season 6 of Game of
Thrones.
We’ve gotta a lotta characters brought low,
beaten down, disempowered, disillusioned,
dead, but there’s also a strong sense of
rising for revenge, with Sansa, and Dorne,
and the Lannisters.
We’ve got lots of women kicking ass, we’ve
got religions playing a part, we got magic,
and politics, and everywhere tension is rising.
The stage is set, and for the most part, no
one knows what’s coming next.
Thanks for watching.
If you’d like to see a breakdown like this
for every episode of Season 6, please let
us know by liking, sharing, subscribing, and
commenting what you want to see next.
You might like to check out our videos on
Thoros of Myr, a red priest like Mel who also
has a crisis of faith, and on Jon’s resurrection,
and on Arya’s character arc.
Thanks to all supporters on Patreon, including
Christopher Brinser, Evan Windsor, Connor
Blanck, Yenyo Pal, Faye Harrison, Jessica
O'Keefe, John Crain Welsby, Richard Thomas
Carlson, Colin VanOsten, Jennifer Grasso,
and KEK7go.
Thanks again, see you next time.